I absolutely know I will be the greatest
entrepreneur of this era because I'm
gonna win on the two fronts that people
gonna judge by the mindset is the
operating system of our lives and I'm an
absolute believer in cutting out
negativity going on the offense
way too many entrepreneurs are way too
calculated about what's in it for me if
you can reverse that and think about
what's in it for them you'll find out
that a lot of things are in it for you
need motivation watch attentively
believe nation what's up at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being born in the
Soviet Union move into United States
hustling as a kid selling flowers and
baseball cards helping build his
family's wine business to now try to
become the ultimate entrepreneur of his
generation he's Gary Vaynerchuk and
here's my take on his top ten roses
success volume six joy
let's kick it off with rule number one
seize opportunities technology and the
way we live doesn't care about my
opinion or my feelings and it doesn't
care about yours
either and so you can walk around earth
and judge oh it's so sad that all these
kids can't communicate cuz they're on
the phone anymore and you could talk
about a day and age when it was simpler
and nicer and all this nobody gives up
and if you don't adjust to the reality
of the situation you will be completely
left behind too many people are
executing or hoping or trying to figure
out how to live in a world that used to
be or the way they wish it was versus
attacking the reality of the world and
here is the reality of the world my
friends the cell phones that you're all
holding right now or in your pocket are
the remote controls of our society they
are the single most important thing in
the world there's nothing close whatever
you want to happen in life you first
need somebody's attention and then you
should tell them about it it was called
the newspaper the television and the
radio now it's called a blog a blog or a
podcast it's the same thing
nothing's changed except one thing your
attention is moving to a new place and
leaving an old place I'm making this
very simple very black-and-white very
basic if you do not spend next year
completely obsessing over how you become
successful on Facebook and Instagram you
will be disproportionately less likely
to win the ad product on those two
platforms are disproportionally
underpriced
and that that is where you should be
trading you are grossly under estimating
what's happening right now 98% of people
are grossly under estimating how good it
is right you will look back at this talk
all my content during this era why am i
producing so much content during this
era
am i flying it on the entire world over
and over speaking to this subject it's
because I know what I'm talking about
right now is gonna go away and I think
we can all agree
I'm not hedging up here right now I'm
desperately trying to force this down
your mouth right you heard it and I
believe that 95% of you will not do
anything about it
you'll do enough to make it feel like
you did something and you will regret
not going all-in how many people here
play poker good I don't but if you do
when you have the best hand it's a good
idea to go all-in rule number two no
you're why I absolutely no I will be the
greatest entrepreneur of this era
because I'm gonna win on the two fronts
that people gonna judge by I'll make
enough money so that I'm in the
conversation and I will inspire and help
more entrepreneurs than the rest of the
field combined I'm talking to all of
them because what Elon Musk does in his
actions to inspire is incredible it's
incredible and Steve Jobs and then but
what I'm doing is different and I know
it the end cuz and by the way it's cuz I
want it more something I'm better I just
want that that's the part I want I'm
it's what this whole thing is that's why
the document like people don't even
understand what I'm actually doing that
I'm leaving so much like from a
businessman see but I'm leaving so much
money on the table when money's not to
go no you know what's funny for me money
stop being a goal at $100,000 I couldn't
believe I made a hundred thousand
dollars a year I was like that was it
and since then nothing's been the same
doesn't feel the same not a million not
a million doesn't feel the same hundred
thousand rule number three don't live in
the middle the number one mistake that
people are making in life today
and it's and it's just so unbelievably
obvious is they're living life in the
middle you know 99.9% of the people that
watch or listen to this content
are living in the middle there they're
hedging and making excuses and
justifying why they are not 100% happy
it's because like every other person out
there besides a few select people they
are living in this middle ground and I
just say the middle and when I think
about how you win in business and
entrepreneurship but most of all in life
it's by understanding the macro and
micro opportunities and executions if
you really understand how to break
through how to be in that zone how to
really really really win the game it
comes down to a strategy that looks like
this
are you balancing your ego with your
humility are you balancing your ego with
your humility do you equally think that
you're the greatest of all time and you
can do it and that also you're a piece
of sh and nobody cares when you're gone
rule number four change your mindset I
for example as you know don't love
positioning myself as a motivational
speaker I'm even the content you just
saw but no question the mindset is the
operating system of our lives right and
I'm an absolute believer in cutting out
negativity going on the offense like
positive thinking like what's the
alternative
like practicality I'm a big believer in
that stuff but action is really the
biggest thing huh and and I do believe
that the right mindset leads to the
right actions so yes I do think you have
to listen to me it's about getting
poison out of the system right right I
mean look how many people use in your
situation yeah right yeah because that's
what they decide to think about right
you did it right in the end right it's
binary right and so you know one of the
things I do often is
the people around me they're thinking my
negativity I'm like what's the
alternative there's so much negative
people
you're positive they're running around
with their legs and complaining oh right
right so I'm with you I couldn't agree
more rule number five love the journey
for me a purebred entrepreneur she or he
loves the journey not the stuff you know
one of the things I struggle with in the
current state of entrepreneurship is a
lot of people want the vacations the
watches you know even even the country
business you guys have such an
incredible imagery I think it's
remarkable who doesn't want to find
things in life yeah but I think that if
you're in the game just for the fine
things in life for the models and the
models and the private planes I think
you gonna loose and it definitely is not
my definition of an entrepreneur and my
definition of an entrepreneur is
somebody who can't live without doing
their thing and trying to create
literally suffocated rule number six
give without expectations you know I
think reputation is based on truth and
so in today's world where's nowhere to
hide instead of hiring a PR person in
1994 and getting the right articles I
think it's just delivering crush it for
your employees crush it for your clients
and and fundamentally give without
expectation you know go give a keynote
at a college with no expectation answer
those 10 emails of people reaching out
to you that have nothing to offer you
and just give because you they actually
may have a ton to offer you what I love
is that reputation is becoming a more
transparent game and so the only way to
build the reputation is to do the right
things so over deliver for the ones that
have something or the ones that don't
have something way too many
entrepreneurs are way to calculate it
about what's in it for me if you can
reverse that and think about what's in
it for them you'll find out that a lot
of things are in it for you
rule number seven taste the things you
fear I'm a big believer that it's no
different than swimming or riding a bike
to
that didn't come natural to me I started
swimming and riding a bike late in my
life you know like I think I don't think
I started swimming pose 9 because I
feared that yeah
but the answer was literally to just
jump into pools or swimming to just like
skin your knee right to take in a little
water you know I just think you do it
like I just like I think the best thing
that could happen to you is if you hear
this advice there's a networking event
in town you go you put on your nice
little Manor Media Henry Mays head you
walk up you see somebody you're inspired
by my five minutes with Gary you go up
and go hi to John and John looks at you
and says get the [ __ ] out of my face I
actually think that would be the best
thing that could ever happen to you yeah
I think the best thing that can happen
to somebody when they fear something is
for them to taste the thing they feared
aggressively and immediately when they
could try something yeah I think that it
just eliminates like you'll literally be
there and whether you go crying in the
bathroom or just like becoming silent or
walking out of there or walking and
getting a you know oh you know a
cheeseburger for five seconds and coming
back I think the great thing that would
happen to you is that you'd be like okay
well that happened now what like once
people understand and taste the thing
they fear it becomes a hell of a lot
less scary rule number eight figure out
what you're good at so confident sure of
yourself but when you were just starting
my mom your mom my mom what she do feel
when I was nine years old and opened the
door for an elderly woman at a
McDonald's she reacted as if I won the
Nobel Peace Prize what my mom did was
super smart she overreacted on
everything that I was doing that was a
good human trait and she held me
accountable for things that didn't
matter like grades my mom built huge
self-esteem in me and I feel like the
biggest reason I am Who I am today to
everybody is because I feel so guilty
and so grateful for what she did for me
that I want to do it for everybody else
which is guess what
suck at a tongue good so does everybody
else you also probably pretty rad at
something tries many things as possible
until you figure out what your rad at
and you like and go do that for the rest
of your life and stop giving up
everybody else rule number nine surround
yourself with positive vibes one theme
that I really feel like yo how do I
build my self-awareness how do I build
my optimism how do I change my mindset
it's the people around you if your best
friend is debbie downer you're not gonna
be as optimistic as you can be if the
people that from your town that you hang
out with have no ambition
you're going absolutely nowhere if you
listen to your dad every day about how
the government sucks you're not gonna
love life you've got to audit your inner
circle podcast friends listen to me
listen very carefully to this mashup and
these thoughts because this underlining
tone of who you surround yourself with
absolutely fundamentally changes who you
are period and the story when I hang out
with Silicon Valley in 2005 to 2010 I
was a different dude when I hang out in
the agency land right now I'm a
different dude when I'm like it's when I
was in college at Mount Ida different
dudes like you're a different person and
I'm telling you right now this morning
podcast or this podcast cuz I know some
of you listen to Utley this podcast if I
can get one of you one person listening
to this to dump one loser person in
their circle and add one whoever that
smiley happiest person at work that you
don't talk to that much that's at a
cubicle around the way or that awesome
like that you don't have everybody has
like you have a friend but they're a
friend like one to college with them you
don't really know them but like the
three times you see me you're the
positivist and like the doing things
surround yourself with those people seek
out your friends friend who brings
positive vibes and make them part of
your world and cut out your homie from
college that thinks the world sucks
watch what that addition and subtraction
does to your life and rule number 10 the
last home before a very special bonus
clip is don't change yourself for others
how are you what's your name Elise yeah
well you say I don't okay good okay so
me my I want to become an author okay
just like you amazing and I have been
writing it's my passion and I have I had
applied to this riding my C team and I
spilled my heart I was just me and well
art yes they decline me yes it looks
like it's like they yeah I get it it's
like that's me yes accepting means them
you know what honestly guys first of all
they didn't decline you one random
person that read your declined you then
but it's like a math might read some
stuff up if I changed me they would
probably took me you're wrong you're
wrong
listen in my face I'm telling you right
to your face you're wrong you're valuing
somebody else's opinion too much you're
wrong
I I'm just telling about this is not
this is not a debate you're wrong do you
understand
you're letting one random person listen
you do you understand how many people
would have hired me none who's got
Instagram in here cool go to it right
now please do me a huge favor go to
Instagram go to Gary Vee that's my
account go ten eleven posts back you'll
see my report card I was ranked 243rd
out of 254 in my class 243 at a 254 in
my class you know why because I knew it
was [ __ ]
for me and my not people for you this is
about self-awareness you men to know who
the you are but for me it was [ __ ]
cuz I didn't need it because I wasn't
true I didn't give a [ __ ] what's
Saturday tiny brings Saturn had listen
to me you can't let something be
valuable more than you you're pandering
to them let them come to you take that
same essay and post on instagram with a
photo and see what happens see what
happens let the market decide not some
[ __ ] on managing the person that
read you
good of course it's true and when you're
young in 13 and 15 and 9 do you think
you got to change your because you don't
know how it's played that's why I'm here
to tell you exactly how it's played
one person read your story my dear if
that person
[Music]
now I've got a really special bonus
garyvee clip on be in the trenches but
before that I want to know what did you
learn from this video what lesson
impacted you the most that you're gonna
take an immediate action in your life
for your business leave it in the
comments below I want to hear from you
when you write it down you're much more
likely to actually take action on it so
let's see what you got
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
how do you balance so to find two
everybody how I defined clouds under
clouds to me is like the why the
strategy the macro the big thinking the
big picture the operating system of like
how you do things and then the dirt is
having the humility to go to these
meetings to actually I post all my
Instagram photos the doing the humility
ego humility strategy execution clouds
and dirt the way a balanced it is
they're both important at all times I
can swing back and forth to them I can
literally go from a meeting where like
the call I had on the way out to our
first meeting here today PL was with
vaynermedia's c-suite about a
restructuring of how we handle all our
business super meta and they literally
hung up and I posted something on
Instagram and wrote all the copy as we
were walking into our last meeting to me
I balanced them by doing whichever one
is needed at the time and so I don't
think about it as balancing it I think
about it as time allocation like what
should I be doing with my time and I
think that you know you made a joke of
like we did a shoot for a client that we
debated on the phone for 10 minutes
where them should be located before that
I think that's being in the middle right
I think pandering to the way companies
do things we just had a meeting where
they're like oh that was provocative us
as as the gallery media group holds on
all the other things we do us doing what
every other publishing does company does
is not a good idea that's the middle
that's not gonna get you to the next
place and so for me I'm just in the
mindset of you know do either doing
humble dirty work like the reason I'm
the best strategist in social media out
there I really believe this is because I
do both I both sit at the top of a media
cup of a company that really does it at
scale for the big skimmers a little bit
at the same token there's very few
humans that put out a hundred
forty pieces of content by hand a week
and reads the copy I literally just
replied to Kyle in my client comments oh
and I'm gonna show you because I don't
think you guys believe me when I do
these rants
I literally just replied to Kyle one
second before babbles like let's do this
video like literally what I was doing
one second before then was
replying to literally like literally
hearted Kyle's comment of I'm digging
the recent pics in quotes man right like
many many people watching here would
argue that my time at this point in my
career of reading Kyle's comment and
Harding it in that minute was a bad use
of my time
I think the dirt is the reason why I
come up with such good clouds being in
the trenches drives my strategy I live
in reality and practicality not in
thesis or ideology or reading headlines
or reading about people doing marketing
so I don't I don't balance it I just do
whatever is needed at that second Mac
you know it's back to macro micro micro
speed I'm just always doing something
right Bobby like that is the big
breakthrough everybody on the team says
like there's just every second and so
the reason I can do something every
second is and I don't watch a YouTube
video or stand by the wall water cooler
and talk about the Rockets game for 10
minutes is because I always value the
dirt and so in that half a second that I
had right now in the transition of the
cold that I just had about a macro
Boehner X strategy right the second
transition I had before I started doing
a macro thing like the vlog was Harding
Kyle's two cents on my last Instagram
post clouds and dirt if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple
so it would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]